foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this new video I will be discussing some
of the new information that was released
over the holidays now during this last
week there have been a lot of new
updates regarding House of the dragon as
well as the other Game of Thrones shows
HBO has in development I want to make
this video as a way to show you exactly
what was said because as always there is
a lot of misinformation out there as
well in fact if you have been following
any of the Game of Thrones fan accounts
on Facebook then you might have already
seen some fans saying the Jon Snow show
is no longer in development
my name is Jon Snow your grace
I'm Ned Stark's son well I'm here to let
you know that it's false there have been
no new updates or announcements
regarding the Jon Snow series now George
RR Martin did announce that HBO was
shelving some of the shows that are in
the early stages of development however
he did not mention Jon Snow's show as a
matter of fact he did not name any of
the Game of Thrones successor shows at
HBO let me show you exactly what he said
that way you will have a better
understanding of what's Happening inside
HBO when George RR Martin's not a Blog
website he gave us a new update about
everything that's happening in his A
Song of Ice and Fire Universe he said
another Christmas has come and gone and
the New Year looms just ahead where the
hell does all the time go I did take a
few days off for the holidays I confess
shame on me I guess but now I'm back in
the salt mine working working on so many
bloody things my head May explode soon
yes wins of winter yes yes and House of
the dragon's second season and several
of the other successor shows that we're
developing with HBO some of those are
moving faster than others as is always
the case with development none of them
have been greenlate yet though we are
hoping maybe soon now a couple of them
have been shelved but I would not agree
that they are dead you can take
something off the shelf as easily as you
can set it on the Shelf alright so as
you can see George RR Martin said HBO
has set at least one of the Game of
Thrones successor shows on the Shelf he
did not mention what show so I'm not
sure why so many fans are saying the Jon
Snow series is dead for all we know the
Jon Snow show is one of the shows that's
moving along faster than the others as
he mentioned in the update remember they
still have several shows in development
at HBO they have been working on shows
about nymeria the sea snake Jon Snow and
Duncan egg out of those four shows alone
I would say the Jon Snow show has some
of the best odds of getting made
considering it's directly connected to
their flagship show as you all know Game
of Thrones is their Mothership and Jon
Snow was its commander-in-chief if one
of these shows did get set on the back
burner my guess is it's the show about
nymeria but that's only speculation as
of right now no one can confirm what
shows are moving forward unless George
RR Martin or someone at HBO makes an
official announcement so make sure you
set the record straight if you see
anyone saying the Jon Snow show is no
longer getting made now in other recent
news one of House of the dragon's
writers reveals they are finishing the
writing for House of the Dragon season
finale of its second season and they
said the fans will not be disappointed
they're essentially hyping up what might
be one of the greatest moments from the
series in a new article written by
variety its headline reads House of the
dragon's writer teases season 2's blood
and cheese now those words or I should
say those names should strike fear in
the hearts of those who have read George
R Martin's Fire and Blood so some of you
might be wondering what is blood and
cheese and why is it going to be such a
big deal without giving away any Major
Spoilers from Martin's Fire and Blood
The Song of Ice and Fire novel that
describes the Targaryen family history
and serves as the source material for
House of the Dragon Blood and cheese are
the nicknames given to the characters
who are responsible for carrying out a
Revenge plot against Allison amond king
aegon and the greens on behalf of Damon
and rhaenera Targaryen and the blacks
following renera's son lucari's death at
the hands of Amen on the Game of Thrones
series Luke's death is depicted as
somewhat of an accident with Eamonn
looking shocked following the Fatal
outcome of their dragon fight in the
season 1 finale
wait
wait my Lord strong
now whether the death was unintentional
or not House of the Dragon writer Sarah
Hess has confirmed HBO's successor show
will include the blood and cheese plot
that followed Luke's death in the novel
a brutal trade that fire and blood's
demon describes as an eye for an eye a
sun for a son we are currently writing
the finale of season two hess told
variety when asked last month if the
house of the Dragon writer's room had
already wrote the on-screen version of
the infamous blood and cheese storyline
she finishes her interview by saying I
don't think you will be disappointed so
as you can see according to variety
House of the Dragon writer Sarah Hess
has already confirmed we will without a
doubt see blood and cheese next season
now I don't know about all of you but
this makes me very excited although I
did already assume this would happen
two men were found one was a former gold
cloak the other a rat catcher in the red
keep who knew all its secrets
history remembers them only as blood and
one night Queen Helena entered the Royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand they told her that a debt was owed
a son for a son blood and cheese
demanded she choose which Sun would be
ripped from her forever
Queen Helena pleaded with the man to
kill her instead but they refused
weeping Helena named her younger son
Melo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
perhaps because the older boy was King
aegon's first-born son and Heir you hear
that little boy she's whispered to the
younger son your mama wants you dead
then blood struck off the older boy's
head with a single blow when the guards
burst in they found Queen Helena still
screaming clasping her dead son's body
to her mad with grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
it does already seem like the second
season will be far better than the first
there has been a lot of new information
getting released regarding the filming
of the second season I will be making a
separate video about all of that so I
hope I will see all of you back here for
that one as well let me know what you
think about these recent updates and
announcements I'm interested in hearing
what you have to say as always I want to
thank all of you for watching another
video now that the holidays are over I
hope everyone has an amazing New Year
have a great day everyone I will see you
again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign